russia has been accused of committing
war crimes against ukraine and some have
called putin a war criminal oh i i i
think he is a war
but what is a war crime
like any crime they involve breaking the
law because even war has rules and
they're set out in international law and
treaties international humanitarian law
says what can and can't be done during
war
it aims to save lives and reduce
suffering there are three main
principles the first is distinction
that's distinguishing between civilians
and armed combatants
civilians and civilian objects must
never be attacked
second is proportionality this is
weighing up the military advantage of an
attack with incidental civilian deaths
injury and damage to civilian objects
and finally there is precaution
this is taking constant care to spare
civilians during attacks the geneva
conventions and their protocols are the
main basis for international
humanitarian law the convention was
first signed in 1947
after the atrocities of world war ii and
the nuremberg trials and has been
ratified by 196 countries there are four
conventions relating to wounded and sick
soldiers during conflict war at sea
prisoners of war and civilians
certain grave breaches of the
conventions always constitute war crimes
both states and individuals can be held
responsible for war crimes
the international criminal court or the
icc investigates and tries people
charged with genocide war crimes crimes
against humanity and the crime of
aggression
it sits in the hague in the netherlands
and has indicted 45 individuals since it
began operating in 2002.
a handful of countries don't recognise
the icc including russia the u.s and
china
members of the icc could have to
imprison convicted persons and that
includes the uk
radovin karadich who was convicted of
genocide in bosnia and charles taylor
who was convicted of war crimes in
sierra leone have both served their
sentence in the uk
prosecutors humanitarian lawyers
journalists and civilian activists have
all been gathering evidence of alleged
war crimes in ukraine
ukraine
in my view
has
clearly has strong evidence of of the
most serious war crimes and probably
crimes against humanity the icc is among
those who have sent a team to
investigate
to issue an arrest warrant prosecutors
need to prove reasonable grounds to
believe that war crimes were committed
what we look for in cases such as these
were where you're looking at shelling
rocketing aerial attacks and so forth as
we tend not to focus on a specific
incident
we're looking at patterns the key
is
somewhat paradoxically it's it's not
safe footage
uh from the crime scenes we're actually
looking for material generated by the
attacking force
and many including government ministers
have said there are clear evidence of
war crimes happening it's a war crime
because
under international law
you cannot attack
health facilities hospitals
what you see on your tv screens
is a war crime
yes so the targeting of civilians or
civilian infrastructure is is a war
crime international law requires special
protection for nuclear facilities and it
is difficult to see how russia's actions
were compatible with its commitments
under article 56
of the additional protocol of the
geneva's conventions
since its inception the icc has overseen
30 cases and in the past separate
tribunals have also investigated war
crimes
for example in 1993 the un created a
separate international criminal tribunal
the international tribunal for the
former yugoslavia is now in session to
examine alleged crimes that took place
during the broken wars
russia has denied all claims of civilian
targeting and describes the invasion as
a special operation i don't think we're
committing war crimes in ukraine are you
saying that civilian
homes playgrounds hospitals theaters
have not been targeted by russia in
mario paul they were not targeted
and you know it's very well we said from
the very beginning
that our military is not the threat for
civilian population ukraine
from gathering evidence to attempting to
secure a conviction a trial would be
lengthy and complex for putin to be
prosecuted for war crimes the icc would
have to prove he was responsible for
them
putin would have to be arrested too
which could be very difficult as he's
unlikely to leave russia anytime soon
without russia's cooperation bringing
other defendants to trial would also be
difficult